the chinese city of yuwu home to
products for worldwide export including
christmas decorations e-scooters and
solar power systems
shams shinwari and gazi ahmad zai have
been exporting from yiwu to kabul for 10
years but now trade with afghanistan is
at a standstill
i hope in the future in next six months
everything will be goes to normal we are
more requested to china government help
us in regarding the
business with the afghanistan so this is
the most important thing for us
ahmad zai usually sells solar panels to
aid organizations which then donate them
to afghan families
don't have ngos already closed many
offices
and maybe we hope in future they can
come back and open their office and open
their injuries and help help our peoples
and help their business stay afloat the
two say they aren't worried about the
safety of their families back in
afghanistan but they are worried about
being able to provide for them if trade
remains disrupted
chinese businessman yumingui has set up
a trade center in kabul
he tells us why the chinese like
afghanistan
we chinese don't get involved in
politics or religion only in trade
afghanistan offers many export
opportunities for china especially for
everyday goods not high-tech products
in late july chinese foreign minister
wang yi boldly met a taliban delegation
in china nearly three weeks before the
group's invasion of kabul
his demand
what happens in afghanistan cannot
endanger stability in the region
it's a position that beijing continues
to push
that's partly because afghanistan's
easternmost tip borders china's xinjiang
uighur autonomous region
international researchers say it's here
that china has established a police
state and locked hundreds of thousands
of muslims in re-education camps
something beijing denies
the two afghan entrepreneurs in yiwu
hope that the situation in afghanistan
stabilizes soon
for their families and for their
businesses
i hope china
can get this point because the one who
was fighting
now they're in the politics so they want
to rebuild afghanistan so no need to be
worried about this as i think
but can the taliban secure a new era of
trade with china and as powers shift in
the region who will reap the benefits
we have journalist reed standish from
radio free europe joining us he's been
reporting on china afghanistan relations
read there was also a recent shipment of
afghan pine nut exports to china which
the chinese ambassador made a big show
off on social media you can see here he
says it's income for afghan farmers and
a nice taste for chinese consumers
win-win
okay i mean in the grand scheme of
things though is trade between the two
countries really that important
um no i mean i think especially for
china this is a very insignificant
amount of trade that's happening on but
for afghanistan this definitely has a
big impact um and i think that this is
really being driven out of concern
coming from china but also across all
for all of afghanistan's neighbors about
you know how bad and dire the
humanitarian situation is right now in
the country um you know the taliban
don't have access to a lot of funds
they've received some aid and some
assistance but a lot of it is frozen
internationally at the moment and
china's trying to paint this narrative
you know that win-win cooperation which
we see that china says around the world
that it's stepping in and you know
filling a void um that's happening right
now in the uh in afghanistan but i think
that there's also just generally a lot
of concern across the region for how bad
things could get in the future in terms
of the humanitarian situation so china
is also trying to be uh you know
preemptive here and stave off something
that could get worse
yeah speaking of stability i want to
pivot to discuss security i assume it's
not the pine nuts china is really after
i wonder how serious is the situation
with uighur militants training in
afghanistan or is this an example of
chinese paranoia over terrorism
um i mean it's always difficult to say i
mean the
issue of weaker militants especially in
afghanistan has always been something
that's shrouded in mystery when you talk
to a lot of you know experts and
analysts who have followed these things
for decades you know they've always are
keen to put out that this is a relative
always has there's been a very small
amount of people weaker militants based
in afghanistan um in terms of the exact
number that exists right now we're not
really sure um the most official figure
that exists was a report from last year
from the u.n security council which said
that there's believed to be about you
know 500 militants in the country but of
course anything that passed through the
security council also has the input of
china so it's it's difficult to say but
of course um you know the terrorist
threat coming from the country um both
towards china and i mean towards its
neighbors is something that's very real
um and so that um is something to watch
i think moving forward
now there's been a lot of chatter as you
know after the fall of afghanistan about
a power vacuum in china's potential new
role in the region
um how much credence should we give this
well i think it's very important to say
right away you know china has no desire
to fill the vacuum left by the united
states that's not what china is going
for here um but of course there's as
we've already talked about there's a lot
of worry about how bad the situation
could get both the security situation
the humanitarian situation
um and so china is trying its best to to
wall itself off from these threats you
know it shares a small but you know not
tiny border it's about 76 kilometers i
believe with with afghanistan
and um
but you know china has no desire to have
really boots on the ground in
afghanistan or anything resembling what
we saw with the united states and even
when it comes to you know some of the
the bigger economic role that was talked
about from from china towards
afghanistan about mining rights for rare
minerals all these things you know these
are concessions that china has held for
a really long time and the fact that you
know china didn't take advantage of them
under the previous afghan government
when the security situation was much
better in the country i mean i think
that also shows that you know they're
not going to go in now so i think moving
forward the the big game for china is
you know how do we protect ourselves
from the threats in afghanistan coming
across all borders and that's really
what beijing has on its mind at the
moment
now looking more at the security
situation of course we sort of circle
back to the economic situation and the
prospects look pretty bleak
i wonder i guess we should continue to
expect big parts of afghanistan to
continue to produce opium
um i mean definitely that's been part of
the the afghan economy for for decades
and despite you know the taliban talking
about desire to to crack down on this i
mean i think that's even if there is a
genuine desire from the taliban uh being
actually being able to do this is uh you
know a very difficult task it didn't
happen in the united states um it didn't
happen under the soviet union um i
wouldn't expect it to really happen
right now under the taliban um so i
think moving forward this is going to be
part of the future of afghanistan and
it's going to continue to be a big issue
for all of afghanistan's neighbors as
well
reid standish thank you so much for
joining us
thank you